[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Hi, and welcome
back to "VM End-to-End,"
a show where we have a VM
enthusiast and a VM skeptic--
or former VM skeptic--
hash out all things VMs.
If you remember the
show from last season,
we talked about reliability,
automation, costs,
and all of the benefits that you
can get from cloud-native VMs.
But there are still some
things I'm confused on,
so I brought Brian back
in to talk about it.
Brian, hi.
I need to know why I
can't have just one giant
super machine that just
works, instead of all
these little flimsy parts.
BRIAN DORSEY: That
would be amazing,
wouldn't it, just an
infinitely large machine?
But that is not a thing.
And this season, we're going
to bring some guests in
to dig deeper into
some of these concepts.
So to tell us more about
why that isn't a thing
and how to get
reliability out of things,
we brought in Steve McGhee.
Hey, Steve.
STEVE MCGHEE: Hey, guys.
How's it going?
CARTER MORGAN: Hi, Steve.
Glad to have you here.
Can you tell us a little bit
about yourself and who you are?
STEVE MCGHEE: Sure.
I'm Steve McGhee.
I was an SRE in Google for
about 10 years, and then I left,
and I became a
customer of cloud.
And I learned how
to cloud, and how
to use all the different
clouds, and just how difficult
it is actually to make
decisions and stuff like that.
And then I came back to
Google to help more customers
do exactly that.
I tend to focus on reliability,
because my background was
in site reliability engineering.
CARTER MORGAN:
See, this is great.
Because something I'm
trying to figure out
is, people that are focused on
reliability, you would think
that-- or at least
I would think that--
and Brian has said that I might
be a little misguided here--
that just having one
piece of hardware
that you upgrade and put
a lot of resources into
is going to be a lot
more reliable than having
lots of smaller parts
that have to communicate,
that can all fail.
So where am I going wrong here?
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah.
I mean, your intent is correct.
It would be sweet if we just had
an infinitely dense, infinitely
fast computer.
When you work on a system on
your laptop, the whole phrase,
"it works on my machine,
and what's the problem?"
When we go into production,
we're scaling up.
And we have to
scale up because we
don't want to have a
service for one person.
We hopefully want
it for many people,
potentially even around the
world or something like that.
So being able to scale
up into production
means that we run into
actual laws of physics.
So speed of light comes into
play, density of material.
You can't go so dense that
everything catches fire,
for example.
That would be bad.
And so that means we have to
start spreading things out.
What it really
means is that we're
taking what was one computer,
and we're spreading it
across time and space, and we're
using many computers instead.
So I hope that helps understand
what the basic problem is here.
CARTER MORGAN: It really does.
Because we've talked
about this a lot.
Brian hammered home
a point last season.
He said, a cloud VM is
a slice of a data center
more so than it was a slice
of one specific machine.
And so it seems like
that's playing out here.
But what I don't understand is,
Google touts its reliability
and being able to be
up for a long time.
But how is it able to do
that with so many parts
that are constantly going
to fail, like a disk?
STEVE MCGHEE: If you think
about what it used to be like,
during the dot-com
boom, we used to call
these gold-plated servers.
We would make the most
expensive solid server
that you could ever have with
many nicks, and many power
supplies, and many
everythings, and hot swappable
this and that.
And those were pretty awesome.
They lasted really, really well.
But they were super expensive.
And it turns out that
just putting all your eggs
into the basket, making the
one machine really reliable,
only gets you a little
bit of the return.
Because you still have to have
some downtime for maintenance,
and scaling up, and
things like that.
And so what we found
inside of Google
is that we found
we actually wanted
to horizontally scale,
which is adding more
machines at a time in order
to achieve planet-wide scale,
like have billions of
users, for example.
You can't fit billions of users
on one very expensive machine.
So once you start
horizontally scaling,
using the most expensive machine
possible with marginal return
doesn't really make sense.
And so instead of having
a really solid base,
we introduced resilience at
many layers in the stack.
And it turns out that is
way better for the service.
It's more economical,
and it actually
allows you to move faster, which
sounds crazy, but it's true.
BRIAN DORSEY: This shows
up in a lot of places
in Google Cloud around the VMs.
The VMs themselves are
insulated to some degree
from the underlying systems
that are live migration.
We've got different zones
of separation between them.
We have load balancers so
you can hit different pieces.
But it feels like there's a
core principle here or two.
I don't know if you could talk
a little bit more about that.
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah.
So I went to school
in computer science,
so I consider myself a
computer scientist, I guess,
or a software engineer.
And I think everyone who's
super into computer science
knows the one holy thing
is layers of abstraction.
Abstraction solves everything.
So really this is what
we're talking about here,
is that we're going to have
many layers of abstraction.
And I jokingly refer to
this as like the matryoshka
doll, which is those little
nesting dolls you've seen.
At the very middle, the tiny
little doll is your CPU.
And then it goes
up to a machine,
and it has a VM around
it, and then in a rack.
And it's in a data center,
and then the data center
is part of a zone, which
is then part of a region.
And so at every layer
of this stack, if you're
able to perform some resilience
engineering to make sure
that you can take advantage
of that layer of the stack,
this is where you get really--
it's like
defense-in-depth, right?
So you're able to
handle failures
at any level of this stack.
Because disks fail.
CPUs can go out.
Solar flares can cause
memory corruption.
Someone can cut a fiber
line to a data center,
and the whole building could
potentially go offline.
We have floods happen.
I mean, they're rare.
Fires happen.
They're rare, too.
So there's lots of
potential failure modes
that you have to
consider, and they
happen at many of these levels.
So being aware of all those
and having mitigations ready
for them is super important.
BRIAN DORSEY: It's funny.
We're calling it virtual
machines in the cloud,
but it's really virtual
machines, and virtual disks,
and virtual load balancers and--
STEVE MCGHEE: That's right.
I really liked what you said
in the previous episode,
that you're getting a
slice of a data center.
Because we're able to take
all these component parts
and present them to a customer
as this nice abstraction.
Like, it's this
computer, with this disk,
and it has this network.
And in actuality, it might
be, the one disk you have
is actually three disks.
But we're not really
showing you all three disks.
It's just like magically
giving this resilience
and redundancy to you.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
I see how being able
to abstract away
the layer underneath
yourself and saying,
I don't care exactly which
zone is under this region.
As long as one of
them is up, I'm fine.
That actually makes sense.
And it makes sense
why we wouldn't
want one supercomputer.
Because it'd be hard to do that.
But then now you have
to start managing
all these separate zones and VMs
and all this extra complexity
that comes in, which is one of
the downsides of abstraction
sometimes.
How does Google handle that?
STEVE MCGHEE: A good question.
I work with a lot of companies
that ask exactly this.
They say, great.
You want us to spread all of
our computers around the planet?
That doesn't sound like a
pain in the butt at all.
You know, it sounds like,
well, how in the heck
do you expect me
to deal with that?
And again, the answer
comes back to abstraction.
So when you think about
it, you have one VM,
and the first step you're
going to get is many VMs.
So we put these
together, and we put them
behind a load balancer.
We call this a service.
If you're familiar
with Kubernetes,
it's pretty much the same idea,
where you have a bunch of VMs,
and you have an entry point
that talks to all of them.
If you can then
take this service
and you can run it
across multiple zones,
now we can call this
a regional service.
Because it now lives across many
of these zones in one region.
And then if you can get
that regional service
in many regions, I call
this a distributed service.
There's no canonical
name for that right now.
But the idea is that it's
many of these services,
but they all do the same
thing, and they represent
the same business need.
And so you're able to now handle
regional level events as well.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
I'm putting all this together.
I'm trying to really
piece this together.
Because it's still
hard to me to think,
these things can
go down so often,
and that gives you
more reliability
because you're layering
on top of each other.
Maybe Brian-- you're always good
at giving me concrete examples.
Where do we use this
in Google Cloud?
BRIAN DORSEY: So I think
the most common example
is when you have multiple VMs
that are doing the same job.
Maybe they're a web server
or something like that.
And you put a load
balancer in front of them.
And this shows up in
physical installations,
and it shows up in the cloud.
It's maybe the most
common example of this.
So you have one
endpoint, and you
have multiple different back
ends that can do the work.
And if one of them goes
away, the work still happens.
So I think that's my
favorite specific example.
But Steve, is there a more
general principle at work here?
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah, totally.
So an analogy to think about
is, just think about boats
in the water, physical boats.
If you poke a hole in the
bottom of your dinghy,
you're going to have
a bad day, right?
That's no good.
So we call this "one
failure domain."
Your little dinghy
is a failure domain.
Because there's only
one floor to it.
And if you put a hole
anywhere in that floor,
it's going to flood.
That's not great.
But then now think
of a bigger ship.
Think of a container ship or
some giant vessel of some kind.
They're like a bunch
of little boats
tied together, because they have
these things called bulkheads.
So I wouldn't do
this, but you could
poke one hole in the bottom
of one of these big ships,
and it would be fine.
Because what it would do is,
it would fill up that bulkhead,
but the rest of the boat is so
buoyant that it stays floating.
So essentially, you're
taking these things that
could fail with a hole, and
you stick them together,
and now the system as
a whole doesn't fail
with that same failure mode.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
that's exactly what's
going on with our VMs and
load balancer kind of thing.
How does this work?
So if you've got VMs,
and load balancers,
and these different bits--
and you mentioned zones,
and regions, and
distributive services--
how do we reason about this?
How do we decide
how much complexity
we're going to put into this?
STEVE MCGHEE: A good question.
Yeah, that was kind of the
abstract, academic answer.
And so now let's talk
about reality, Steve.
This is an important
thing, to understand
what level of
availability you can
expect from the systems
you're building on top of.
How often do we get a hole
in the bottom of a boat?
Can we get a number?
That would be nice.
The way that we suggest
people think about it
is that, for something
that lives in one zone,
we say it's going to be
available 99.9% of the time.
Specifically, we say its
design is to be available
99.9% of the time.
That basically means
it's going to be
down or unavailable
for 40 minutes a month.
And it's important
to think that's not
the best-case scenario or
the worst-case scenario.
That's something you can
pretty much count on.
So it's pretty much
going to happen.
Similarly, if you
have something that
is across many
zones in a region,
we call that four nines.
It's 99.99% available.
And the way to
think about that is,
it's 40 minutes a
year of downtime,
which is actually pretty good.
Computers stay up quite a lot.
40 minutes in an entire
year, it's a tiny--
I mean, we know exactly how
big of a fraction it is.
But sometimes maybe that's
still not acceptable for you.
But it's up to what
it is that you're
putting in these computers.
Are you OK with those three
nines or those four nines?
And you have to make a decision
on what's appropriate for you.
CARTER MORGAN: I get this
now because basically you're
saying, OK, I have two computers
that are only down 40 minutes
every year.
If we layer them over each
other, when one's down,
the other one's not down.
We're good.
And so it's just
interesting seeing
all of this that comes in that
you have to manage on your own.
I wonder if I have to come in
as the developer and be like,
OK, I have to
schedule this computer
to be up watching for
the other one to be down,
or is this something that
the infrastructure can
start to take care of for you?
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah.
The good news is that
this is a problem
that, inside of Google
for the past 20 years,
we've been dealing with.
And so we've come up with a
bunch of solutions, basically--
a bunch of improvements
to the system.
And we're bringing those
to Cloud customers.
And so for example, we
know that sometimes you
have to power down a rack
of machines or something
like that.
And if your server is on
that rack, what do you do?
That's a real bummer.
Should we tell you ahead of
time or something like that?
But instead, we built this thing
called live migration, which
basically takes the soul of your
machine, the running system,
the running software,
and it transports it
magically across the room or
whatever to another machine.
And that way, we can safely
power down this rack,
bring it back up.
And maybe we had to replace
a fuse or something,
I'm not really sure.
And basically, it's one less
thing for you to worry about.
And when I said
before that machines
are designed to have
99.9% of availability,
it accounts for stuff like this.
So this is how we're giving
you 99.9% availability.
There's a bunch of
other stuff too.
Sometimes the building we
need to do maintenance on,
or maybe the machine
itself, has a problem.
Or who knows?
There's all kinds of
things that could go wrong.
And we aggregate all that
risk into one number,
and then we give you
that expectation.
And you basically
don't have to worry
about all those weird
things that could go wrong.
You just know this machine
is going to be up 99.9%
of the time.
BRIAN DORSEY: So there's a
whole bunch of these edge cases,
I guess, if you
will, that are just
handled because you're
running a VM in a cloud,
instead of on an individual
physical machine.
So we've got all of those.
We've got these tools.
If something similar is
happening at the disk level,
we've got load balancers
that are built out
of lots of machines, kind
of data center-level things.
We've got groups of VMs,
like managed instance
groups, and then
zones, and regions,
and all this kind of stuff.
But then I don't know.
Some of it is to the app
level problem, right?
CARTER MORGAN: You're
saying you want
to design an
application that can
handle this 40 minutes of
downtime in year two as well?
That's interesting.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
OK, so we get to the point
where we can trust the VMs
and then build from
there, I guess.
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah.
The important point is to
know what level of trust
you can put into the VM.
And what you're really
doing is, you're
putting that trust into the
hands of your cloud provider.
And you're saying, look, just
tell me what it's going to be.
And on GCP, for our
VMs, we tell you,
it's going to be 99.9
for one VM in one zone.
And then it just means that you
get to put that all that out
of your mind, and you
can trust that number
is going to be true.
And now you have
to work around it.
It's important that you don't
think that that number is close
enough to 100-- let's
just say it's 100%--
because that's not true.
If you make a distinction
between 99.9 and 100,
you're going to make actually
radically different design
choices in your application.
You're going to start to
introduce things like retries,
or you're going to introduce
things like checkpointing,
or you're going to allow your
service to potentially live
in two places at the same time.
What if one request
comes in here,
and one request comes in
there, and this one's up,
and this one's not?
Now that you've allowed
a little bit of failure
into your understanding
of the model,
you change the way you think
about designing your system.
And to me, that was one of
the fundamental things that
made Google succeed
from the very beginning,
was that we designed our systems
to allow some form of failure.
And then we just added that
resiliency over and over
and over again, all the
way through the stack.
CARTER MORGAN: This
is so interesting.
Because the way you just
worded that, it finally
made it click for me.
By planning for
failure, it doesn't
matter what the
failure is, because I
have the case covered.
It's going to be some delay to
getting this information to me
in some way.
So I'll retry it.
I'll do something like that.
And then that allows you
to build more resilience
and reliability.
And again, it's an abstraction
away from the core thing.
I don't care why it's that.
Let me abstract.
To put it in the
real world, there
are some important use
cases where this matters.
And that's why there's so much
effort going into this thought.
STEVE MCGHEE: That's right.
It's important to not
try to get the highest
level of reliability out
of absolutely everything.
Because you're going to have
some websites, or services,
or whatever that can be down.
It's no big deal.
It's not a problem.
But there are other
services which
are actually really important.
So let's say there's a service
out there that responds when
someone needs to get a new
delivery of oxygen tanks
to some medical center
or something like that.
We should probably
make sure that that one
works most of the time.
And even if you make a request
and it doesn't work right away,
but we know that once we
put it in, it was received,
and someone will take action
on it or something like that--
this is a silly
example, but there
are more and more of
these services that
are becoming more and more
important to the world.
Because frankly,
we're just putting
more of our society online.
So I think COVID is
actually an interesting time
to go through this whole
reliability effort.
Because we saw a lot
of services became
more and more important
to individuals
in an accelerated kind of way.
It was already getting
more important.
But during the last couple of
years, it went really steep.
So think about video
conferencing for school kids,
or just ordering
things from home.
Being able to do this online
is becoming more important.
So making sure that you can
do it when you want to do it
is more of a big deal
even than it used to be.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
things getting very real.
More of our life goes online.
It matters more and is
more and more critical.
So OK, this has been amazing.
I think we're going to
have to wrap up this one.
But I feel like there's a
lot more to talk about here.
And so Steve, would you be up
for coming back and talking
specifically about
what questions
you ask about
whether you're going
to try to get another nine, and
then how do you actually do it?
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah, I
think I can make it.
That should be fine.
I think this is an
important thing.
People really want to
hear about this stuff.
So I'd love to come back.
CARTER MORGAN: Hey, well,
thank you so much, Steve.
Brian, thank you so much.
If you're listening at home,
please write in the comments
if there's anything you've
learned about reliability.
I know I learned a few
things, maybe you did, too.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]